bonjour et bienvenue pour le 7 8
weekends le magazine de vos loisirs nous
allons parler musique et sport dans
cette émission Tout d'abord une
exposition
et jusqu'au 8 février l'espace de
Coville à Voisins le bretonneux
accueille deux artistes une exposition
conjointe entre Béatrice levoyé elle est
sculptrice et claire de la Varenne elle
est peintre ce sont deux amis une solide
amitié artistique les unis Catherine
zulato pour ce reportage sur des images
de David charpentier
l'une est sculptrice l'autre peintre une
solide amitié inhibéatrice le voyait
éclaire de la Varenne la première est
d'abord historienne avant de se former à
la peinture sur des corps et de réaliser
des trompe l'oeils et détrompe l'oeil
devenu des sculptures j'ai toujours été
très attiré par l'être humain dans
toutes mes études d'histoire ce qui
m'intéressait c'était beaucoup plus la
vie de l'homme à travers à travers
l'histoire donc à travers les guerres
etc et autres c'était pas du tout le
plan stratégique Béatrice le voyez
mettent en scène des tableaux de la gare
de 1870 réalisé par l'un de ses ancêtres
Alphonse de Neuville c'est d'ailleurs
l'une de ses réalisations qui touchent
le plus clair de la Varenne j'aime
énormément tout ce qu'elle a tiré des
tableaux d'Alphonse de Neuville j'aime
énormément toute la vie qu'il y a de ces
petites scènes tout ce que elle dit sur
l'humanité de ses soldats et puis aussi
il y a tout un souci du détail car de la
Varenne elle a fait l'école du Louvre si
elle parle aussi bien de son ami c'est
que la aussi a le sens du détail elle
aurait aimé être conservatrice de musée
et c'est finalement dans les tableaux
anciens qu'elles puissent en inspiration
c'est la restauration de tableaux qui
m'a donné envie de me mettre à la
peinture j'avais toujours beaucoup
dessiné j'ai toujours aimé faire des
portraits et puis là j'ai eu envie de me
mettre à la peinture ça fait une
peinture qui paraît très très ancienne
mais je me dis aussi que ce qu'on peut
voir dans beaucoup d'expositions
aujourd'hui ça existe déjà depuis 100
ans alors après tout pourquoi s'inspirer
d'oeuvre qui ont 100 ans ou bien de 100
ans ou bien 300 ans et c'est mon univers
aussi les deux femmes se côtoient très
régulièrement depuis 10 ans elles
exposent pour la cinquième fois ensemble
on s'apporte toutes les deux un regard
très différent elle vient d'un monde de
l'École du Louvre elle est extrêmement
cultivée au niveau artistique moi je le
suis très peu au niveau artistique en
revanche je venais du monde de la
peinture en décor donc plus technique
plus que jamais côté plus artisan et les
deux se sont rejoints et donc on
s'apporte mutuellement un regard
un regard neuf et quand on demande à
Béatrice de choisir un tableau de Claire
elle préfère s'orienter vers un paysage
c'est peut-être la son petit tableau
d'une saynète
une forme très allongée donc j'aime ce
côté
moins classique c'est un paysage
extrêmement harmonieux ce qui est la
caractérise beaucoup claire une double
exposition et une amitié artistique à
découvrir jusqu'au 8 février à l'espace
de Coville à Voisins-le-Bretonneux
clôture ce week-end dernier le week-end
dernier pardon de la douzième semaine du
son c'est une clôture d'une semaine
nationale qui s'est déroulée à Trappes à
l'école de musique en présence du
président du festival l'ingénieur
acousticien Christian et bonnet mais
aussi du parrain qui était présent au
moins par le son puisqu'il n'a pas pu
faire le déplacement physique c'était le
réalisateur Costa Gavras
prendre conscience de l'importance du
son mesuré son volume à cet essentiel
quand on sait que 15 à 20% des jeunes
ont des problèmes auditifs déterminer le
timbre d'un instrument noté l'acoustique
d'une salle et aller au-delà de la
vision purement culturelle du son voilà
tous les objectifs de cette semaine 12e
du nom à sa création un ingénieur
acousticien ingénieur du son Christian
Hugonnet
il y a une dimension sociétale
extrêmement forte parce qu'on considère
que le sonore quand il est maîtrisé et
bien il permet à tout un chacun de mieux
vivre
de savoir écouter l'autre et le dernier
point c'est une dimension économique
dont on parle pas assez encore c'est la
dimension qui nous laisse à penser que
lorsqu'on s'intéresse au sonore on peut
un pays peut
en tout cas éviter de perdre de l'argent
aujourd'hui équiper des gens et des
prothèses auditives ça coûte de l'argent
un pays qui n'entendrait pas ça serait
un pays qui serait vous à l'échec sera
un plan économique pour Costa-Gavras
réalisateur et parrain de cette douzième
semaine le son c'est un lien
indispensable avec le scénario d'un film
retenu à Londres c'est par téléphone qui
l'exprime sa pensée
avec l'écriture du scénario parce que je
pense que les sons c'est un personnage
du film c'était personnel qui aide le
spectateur à mieux comprendre l'histoire
à mieux comprendre les sentiments des
personnages du film et il aide aussi le
personnage à mieux s'exprimer le son est
donc multiples Christian agonet milite
pour que la pratique musicale des plus
jeunes deviennent obligatoire comme en
Grande-Bretagne aux États-Unis une
pratique que Gabriela Boda Stener mène
au sein de la maîtrise des enfants de
Trappes grâce à la méthode coda ils
apprennent le solfège de façon plus
ludique
la maîtrise des enfants qui a offert un
concert avec l'orchestre professionnel
manifesto en résidence depuis 4 ans dans
la commune un concert de clôture ici
tout un symbole dans ces temps quand
même de violence moi je vois la trappe
qu'il y a des enfants qui sont juifs des
enfants qui sont marocains moi je suis
du Maroc je parle arabe mais je suis
juive donc c'est incroyable parce que
voilà je parle pas hébreu je parle et je
suis française de nationalité et la
musique nous réunit dans tout ça de
manière mais tellement forte puisque on
a chanté Purcell en anglais
on perding en français c'est une
traduction de l'allemand enfin on est
dans le le multiculturel et le tous
vivre ensemble et la musique permet ça
parce que quand on dit dauphin Rémy le
monde entier comprend même les Anglais
qui disent Ibis ils savent aussi dire
d'Auré lui façonne ça c'est un très beau
message
un autre festival vient de se refermer
durant quatre jours un festival
d'artsacré était organisé une exposition
était ainsi proposée sur des contes
d'origine juive Mélanie poquet
Joseph avait une petite veste mais à
force de la mettre tous les jours elle
devient vieille
ou c'est une histoire d'un vêtement qui
diminue qui diminue qui diminue jusqu'à
devenir une chanson et même sur le plan
il y a une petite morale quoi ça veut
dire que vraiment même avec rien si on
veut avoir un regard positif on peut
avoir un regard positif sur les
événements une clarinette un simple
dessin et une histoire une heure de
conte pour faire découvrir le judaïsme à
ses enfants et à leurs parents permettre
au public qui ne connaît pas forcément
le judaïsme de rentrer par le biais du
compte dans un monde
qui s'ouvrent de façon spontanée avec le
compte c'est un outil qui est très
puissant qui permet à chaque spectateur
de d'être d'emblée de plein pied avec
les protagonistes du compte
pour cet artiste classique au départ
l'art sacré et la musique juive était
une véritable découverte l'art sacré
quelque chose de
d'extrêmement puissant extrêmement
important parce que c'est une façon
c'est une forme de prière pour moi c'est
à dire que lorsque je prie les psaumes
avec ma clarinette et avec le texte
hébreu
je suis
prise par la musique puisque c'est la
même le même principe c'est l'alternance
d'un texte musical et d'un texte verbal
seulement là la musique la clarinette se
met à prier avec moi et le texte
est un texte d'une force d'une puissance
et d'une liberté qui qui sont
stupéfiantes
et pour les enfants non seulement pour
les enfants et nous aussi les parents et
un compte avec la clarinette c'était
vraiment très très bien pour les enfants
je trouve que c'était peut-être pas trop
pour les plus petits mais voilà c'était
un éveil à la musique je trouve ça super
sur ces quatre jours de festivals des
concerts du théâtre mais aussi une
exposition peinture sculpture
photographies avec pour thème la lumière
éclat de lumière c'est les uns par
rapport aux autres donc nous avons à
travers ce que nous entendons nous avons
à nous apporter les uns les autres
l'espérance qui est au fond de chacun je
crois que ce qui les a vraiment porté
d'abord c'est le thème tout simplement
ils ont travaillé sur des versets de la
Bible qui est parlé de lumière et ils
ont essayé de l'exprimer en vraiment se
donnant à leur art en fonction de ce
qu'il aurait été demandé
culture juive ou catholique quatre jours
pour découvrir que l'art sacré peut
aussi s'adresser à tous
le 7 8 week-end qui se poursuit nous
parlons donc cinéma les derniers films à
l'affiche depuis ce mercredi qu'on avait
vous pensé vos réactions avec ce
micro-trottoir ce micro dès le 10 moines
ce film était terrifiant honnêtement
c'était angoissant
ça je vais pas tant sur le sanglant mais
en fait ressentir cette personne traquée
en permanence ou qu'elle aille quoi
qu'elle fasse à coup sûr elle se fera
rattraper aussi parfait qu'à l'époque le
même dessin aussi coloré aussi pointu
dans le détail et puis la même magie à
l'époque c'était trop bien parce que
c'était drôle c'était trop bien parce
que moi j'aime bien quand il a dansé
très intéressant
j'aime bien parce que c'est marrant il y
a de l'humour j'aime bien
avait vu les deux premiers du coup elle
avait envie d'aller les voir c'était
c'était bien fait moi j'ai adoré
c'est vachement drôle le dinosaure c'est
bien fait bon après c'est le dernier
film de Robbie Williams aussi
franchement c'est bien
je vous propose maintenant d'écouter le
coup de cœur d'un professionnel du 7e 7e
art comme chaque semaine ce soir Gaëlle
Pineau du grenier c'est la trappe
bonjour cette semaine j'ai vraiment
envie de vous parler d'un film qui me
tient beaucoup à coeur ça s'appelle les
nouveaux sauvages plus qu'un film c'est
un film à sketch puisqu'il y a plusieurs
histoires dans ce dans ce long métrage
qui dure deux heures c'est un film
argentin
donc en version originale c'est des
sketchs qui sont qui sont drôles c'est
touchants c'est cynique c'est beaucoup
d'humour noir et c'est complètement
déjanté on dirait même mal élevé et ça
défoule vraiment donc plein d'adjectifs
c'est un film qui est formidable c'est
le film qu'on a envie de voir quand on
va au cinéma et qui ressemble à aucun
autre film je vous le conseille vraiment
vous avez compris donc c'est les
nouveaux sauvages
donc cette semaine au cinéma Le Grenier
à ça
on va maintenant passer au sport Michael
bonjour également à vous deux invités
avec qui on va parler judo et course
d'orientation et canoë aussi et tout ça
de nuit alors l'actualité sportive va
être très chargée ce weekend dans le
département il y a notamment donc du
judo nous recevons aujourd'hui André
Gallia président de la ligue du judo des
Yvelines alors sans nous parlerons du
championnat de France de judo senior par
équipe un rendez-vous programmé samedi
et dimanche à pas Élancourt elle est en
cours
également sur ce plateau donc Thibault
Grégory alors vous vous êtes chef de
projet sur le note donc un événement qui
organise ce week-end dans la vallée de
Chevreuse à 21h samedi c'est ça c'est ça
alors donc le rendez-vous proposera une
course orientation du VTT du canoë et
tout ça de nuit de nuit alors mais tout
de suite on commence par le judo alors
donc c'est les championnats de France
seniors par équipe ce week-end alors
est-ce que vous pouvez un petit peu nous
parler donc de ce rendez-vous
déjà aussi une première dans les
Yvelines donc
service technique qui nous ont facilité
la tâche et donc aujourd'hui encore nous
sommes en train de monter les
installations je crois qu'on va faire
nocturne même voilà afin d'être prêt
pour demain matin 8h les premières
pesées et donc est-ce qu'il y aura des
têtes d'affiches sur ce rendez-vous
alors disons que le
deuxième division on va dire que c'est
2e couteau en quelque sorte donc les 16
premières équipes seront sélectionnées
pour faire le niveau national et donc il
y aura des yvelinois sur cette
compétition il y en aura deux équipes
évidemment
mais bon on est pas trop mauvais mais
bon dès qu'on a des grands mauvais
dès qu'on a des grands champions ils
portent un petit peu ils sont inspirés
dans les grandes dans les grands
toujours sur le sport
bénévole quoi
j'en suis à ma quatrième Olympia
on a travaillé pendant 8 ans sur le
projet sur sur une en cours et puis
c'est un peu la guéguerre entre la
Communauté d'agglomération et la mairie
de longcourt finalement le projet a été
abandonné par le président de la comité
d'un commercial de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à l'époque
mais aujourd'hui
pour l'instant on est à la case départ
et puis bon le contexte c'est comme on a
pas de
place avec notre mort et là on vient
d'acquérir le trafic et donc le trafic
et la remorque entre le transport les
bascules tableau électroniques des
ordinateurs les écrans de télévision
voilà donc c'est vraiment une lourde
tâche mais bon on est tellement
passionné que
avec le plaisir avec le plaisir on
travaille avec plaisir c'est même pas du
travail c'est un plaisir et le public
viendra nombreux bah j'espère bien
je pense que la mairie d'Élancourt a
fait même la publicité il y a des
panneaux ou
je pense qu'on a attendu le monde quand
même à peu près combien on va faire le
plein le plein c'est en place
480 combattants samedi et 480 le
dimanche
au Palais des Sports c'est l'un des
rendez-vous sportifs du week-end la
compétition il y en a d'autres c'est ça
l'actualité sportive aussi de ce
week-end dans les Yvelines c'est le note
donc un événement organisé dans la
vallée de Chevreuse ce samedi à 21h
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter un petit peu le concept très
rapidement donc le noob tirade c'est un
raid sportif nocturne multisport
organisé par la promotion des étudiants
du Master de mels donc management des
événements et loisirs sportifs de
l'Université Paris-Sud et donc le raid a
une distance de 55 km et généralement il
en est donc actuellement à sa sixième
édition et regroupe quatre épreuves
dites classiques donc du VTT de la
course d'orientation du trail et du Run
and Bike et en fait on a vraiment de ces
épreuves classiques de d'épreuves un peu
plus originales et décalées donc cette
année on aura du canoë en février
et du tiers sportif et la grosse épreuve
cette année ce serait une descente en
rappel de 34 mètres sur le viaduc des
Fauvettes donc dans la vallée et donc ça
s'articule comment cette soirée on
commence par quoi on commence par quoi
alors on va on va donc accueillir les
équipes à 17h30 après avoir monté tout
le village un peu comme disait le
monsieur dans la nuit et donc après ça
le départ a donné à 21h et donc les la
première équipe est attendue vers 2h30
du matin et la course finit à 6h du
matin pour les moins rapides et donc
l'objectif c'est de surprendre quand on
sait que il y a des trails vraiment tous
les trois jours maintenant en France
l'objectif c'est vraiment de surprendre
oui c'est ça c'est donc surprendre à la
base on s'est positionné aussi sur la
nuit parce que en Île-de-France c'est au
final le seul red nocturne au moins
pendant la période hivernale donc c'est
assez décalé c'est vrai parce que il
fait froid canoë en hiver c'est un peu
spécial et mais l'objectif c'est aussi
de pour nous qui sommes étudiants de
rencontré dans on est capable et puis
d'apprendre aussi de transvaser ce qu'on
a appris en théorie en concret et le
froid ça sera pas une difficulté
supplémentaire comment vous allez gérer
froid le froid c'est une difficulté
supplémentaire surtout pour les équipes
c'est une difficulté faut le dire je
pense pour les bénévoles il y a 90
bénévoles qui sont principalement des
étudiants ou alors des personnes qui
travaillent dans des associations de Red
notamment et donc pour nous le froid
c'est surtout
on est là pour le combattre amener le
café pour les bénévoles ils vont pas
courir
et ceux qui font du canon il faut pas
qu'il tombe c'est ça
dangereux du coup c'est pas dangereux
non on n'a jamais eu de problème le
canoë est pas présent toutes les années
mais sur les années où il a été présent
et pourquoi la vallée de la Chevreuse
valait de Chevreuse parce
tout simplement en fait quand on a
réfléchi à l'événement donc on en est
cette année à la 6e édition quand ils
ont réfléchi à l'événement au départ ils
se sont dit qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
dans la vallée de Chevreuse de
sympathique et au final c'est la vallée
de Chevreuse qui a amené le raid et pas
et pas l'inverse en fait on s'est pas
positif dans la voiture on s'est adapté
au final j'ai envie de dire et donc
c'est pour quel type de public du coup
c'est plutôt les étudiants des
professionnels les amateurs de travail
les années précédentes c'était plutôt
pour les professionnels donc du monde du
sport donc qui travaillaient dans des
entreprises type Stade de France des
Décathlon etc cette année et au vu des
dernières années avec l'augmentation du
nombre d'équipes inscrites on a décidé
de d'orienter un peu plus encore le raid
vers les raideurs purs les sportifs qui
sont intéressés par le challenge parce
que parce qu'on a tout simplement envie
de montrer que
que c'est un raid qui attire les
sportifs et qui qui entre un peu
maintenant dans le calendrier certaines
équipes reviennent chaque année et
attendre leur aide et juste pour
conclure il est encore possible de
s'inscrire non malheureusement
heureusement pour nous
75 équipes l'objectif a été oui acquis
il y a deux jours on a eu une note 75e
équipe voilà trop tard donc en tout cas
vous pourrez déjà vous renseigner pour
la suivante c'est ce qu'on imagine que
ça reviendra que c'est régulier j'espère
que ça revient un objectif merci à tous
les deux merci Mickaël également
je sais que donc c'est que c'est un
rendez-vous donc vous n'avez pas manqué
Wilfried ce week-end donc en tant que
grand amateur de football un basket
aussi mais il y a un peu moins ce
week-end donc il y a du football
Versailles troisième reçoit ce dimanche
à 15h Bobigny Academy actuelle 4e pour
le choc de cette 15e journée de Division
d'Honneur la rencontre est programmée au
stade montboron en football américain
les Templiers d'Élancourt débutent leur
saison à domicile ce week-end il
reçoivent des Cougars de
Saint-Ouen-l'Aumône ce samedi à 20h au
complexe sportif Europe le public pour
observer à cette occasion les deux
nouveaux américains de l'équipe le
quarterback Zack show et le défenseur
Kodi redment victoire impérative pour
les Templiers qui visent la première
place du championnat cette année pour
les amateurs de rugby il y a un match à
ne pas manquer ce week-end
Montigny-le-Bretonneux va tenter de
poursuivre sa belle série contre
Saint-André à domicile un match qui
s'annonce passionnant
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et Saint-André et
Saint-André se dispute la première place
du classement si vous voulez assister à
la rencontre les supporter les vers le
match est programmé à 15 au stade Roger
Couderc à Montigny-le-Bretonneux et
toujours en rugby mais cette fois-ci en
promotion d'honneur 50 ans en Yvelines
reçoit ce dimanche à 15h le sixième du
classement chalonnais victoire
impérative pour les 50 chinois qui sont
actuellement la troisième place du
championnat une victoire qui
conforterait leur place sur le podium la
rencontre et programme au stade de Guy
Boniface à Élancourt et un dernier enfin
laisse-moi ce samedi à 20h le Mans
colideur de National 2 avec Le Havre les
ini Montaigne veulent passer seul en
tête pour cela elles doivent s'imposer
face à l'adversaire au complexe Pierre
de Coubertin merci donc Michael on vous
retrouvera lundi pour le 7 8 fort les
résultats de toutes ces compétitions et
merci à vos invités également
on termine donc avec un peu de rêve un
voyage de Guyancourtois ont quitté elle
la France cette semaine a destination de
Buenos Aires ils sont munis de leur sac
à dos et de leur vélo un couple qui a
décidé de traverser l'Amérique du Sud
pendant huit mois William elle les a
rencontrés juste avant le départ
donc voilà Buenos Aires Santiago la
passe en Bolivie Lima au Pérou qui
tourne Équateur Bogota et Carthagène en
Colombie
562 km à parcourir en vélo c'est le
projet fou de Pauline et Clément tout de
travailler dans le marketing et après un
an de préparation ils n'ont pas hésité à
quitter leurs emplois pour réaliser
leurs rêves le but c'est vraiment de
faire une coupure de faire une sorte
d'année sabbatique et de se et de un peu
de faire le projet d'une vie quoi
quelque chose qu'on fera certainement
jamais jamais de nouveau et donc d'en
profiter au maximum et d'en tirer le
maximum le genre de projet qu'on pourra
raconter quand on aura 70 ans nos petits
enfants enfin voilà c'est clair que
c'est une fois dans une vie
trust ce sera la devise de ce couple de
baroudeur pour ces prochains mois et
pour se faire connaître ils ont même
créé un site internet une occasion de
suivre leur périple
c'est de promouvoir cet usage autour de
nous en en parlant en parlant de ce
qu'on vit sur notre blog et donc que
tout le monde puisse le suivre et aussi
en essayant un peu de dresser une sorte
de panorama de l'usage du vélo qui est
fait en Amérique du Sud une initiative
saluée par plusieurs entreprises qui
sponsorisent une partie de leur matériel
on a cette petite balise spot donc il va
rassurer nos parents pendant les 8 mois
donc en fait c'est un GPS satellite où
on a juste appuyer sur un bouton et ça
permet d'envoyer nos coordonnées
l'attitude longitude à une
chaîne de mails qui alimentera aussi sur
notre site internet donc voilà même si
on est paumé au milieu du désert nos
proches seront est-ce qu'on se trouve à
quelques heures du départ Pauline et
Clément vérifient une dernière fois leur
équipement un peu de stress mais surtout
une grande fierté car demain ils seront
les ambassadeurs du cyclotourisme
fin de ce 7 8 weekends je vous souhaite
plein de bonnes activités puis on se
retrouvera lundi pour le journal bien
sûr